okay this is from the new york post says
florida governor ron desantis launched
an offensive against big tech on tuesday
warning that the social media platforms
are targeting politicians like former
president donald trump now
but will soon be coming for regular
american citizens vowing to combat the
threat
uh he said in a news conference quote
today they may come after someone who
looks like me tomorrow they come after
someone who looks like you
as he was announcing the transparency
and technology act
as part of his measure desantis
suggested fines of a hundred thousand
dollars per day for de-platforming
political candidates
as well as daily fines for any company
that quote uses their content and
user-related algorithms to suppress or
prioritize the access of any content
related to a political candidate
or cause on the ballot the governor also
called for allowing people to opt out of
content algorithms requiring
notification about changes in terms of
service
and providing the right of citizens to
take legal action if these conditions
are violated
all of this is great this is all exactly
what
republicans republicans should have done
this
years ago on the federal level and they
could have at least tried they didn't
even try
trump didn't try none of them tried when
they had the chance this is exactly what
needs to happen
um and some of this should be totally
uncontroversial
so yeah if you want to we we could have
a debate about
um rules that stop politic
social media companies from censoring
political political content or political
candidates
i think there should be those rules but
something like
um notification about changes in terms
of service
yeah that's just that is basic
transparency that we expect and legally
require
of most any other company
and oftentimes companies that don't have
nearly the kind of of power and control
over you that big tech companies do
that's all that is what's the argument
against it
you know if if they're gonna if they're
gonna make a change
at a minimum if they're gonna make a
change to the terms of service
um you know you you signed up for the
site thinking one thing
and then they they start tinkering with
it and changing it they should have to
tell you that
and again at a minimum if twitter wants
to decide
that it's going to start purging
conservative accounts as they have been
doing which is why all conservatives are
losing their twitter followers
they should at a minimum have to tell us
that they're doing it and
explain why basic transparency
that we require of any other company
um desantis we'll play some of the clips
from this because i i just think it's
it's great he uh
here he is talking about some of the
things that prompted this
and discussing what twitter did with the
new york post story
and how that's motivating some of what
he's doing now let's watch
hunter biden's story was true okay we
now know was true
and the typical corporate media outlets
they just chose to ignore it
obviously they wanted to beat trump they
had a they had a view on the election
they didn't want to give it any air so
we rely on social media
to go around that not let
corporate legacy media outlets control
the discourse and let us speak
so you had the new york post to run it
and you couldn't get any traction you
couldn't get any reach on it
because big tech put their thumb on the
scale so that was true what they said at
the time
oh it was it was it's a conspiracy or
it's based on
on on hacked information are you kidding
me
you're trying to tell me if there was
hacked information that could damage me
you guys wouldn't print it give me a
break you can whiz on my leg but don't
tell me it's raining you guys would
print it every single day if you could
and big tech would allow it to
proliferate every single day 20
24 7. so it's not being done in a
principled basis
and it's not there's there's threats on
me and it only gets taken down if law
enforcement goes
and tells tells them to do it otherwise
it just stays up they're not moderating
any of that
oh he's absolutely right and if um
once again twitter wants to shut down
the new york post story
and yes that is that is influencing the
election
now maybe you could argue that it
wouldn't be influencing the election
quite as much at least not influencing
it in a dishonest way
if twitter just came out and said
listen we are we're a liberal company
we're a left-wing company this is how we
this is how we run things
we're not interested in conservative
content uh the the content that we're
going to highlight and put in front of
your eyes
that's going to be left-wing content and
if there's a story that we don't like
for political reasons we're going to get
rid of it
at least if they came out and said that
then everyone would know where they
stand and the bias would maybe be a
little bit less harmful
that's why i tend to think that bias
from you know a
from a a news organization like cnn if
we can call them a news organization but
the bias from cnn is is is a
it's indefensible but it's also not very
harmful because everybody knows what
they're getting with cnn
even if they don't admit it uh still
everyone knows
now with twitter there are still a lot
of people who use twitter and are
oblivious to this
they think they're getting an accurate
reflection you know they
the way they what they think is
happening is that when they go to their
news feed on twitter or facebook
that they're going to be exposed to news
and they're going to find out what's
going on
it's what most people think
so twitter should have to be honest
about that
and uh here's desantis touching on
something that i that i also feel i mean
we we talk about the
the bias from twitter which is very
concerning
but that doesn't even hold a candle to
what happened to parlor
uh let's listen to desantis on that what
really i think
scared me was the decapitation of parlor
it wasn't just
it wasn't just some of that stuff it was
the web hosting
the payment processing take away your
email your text
you could totally neuter a candidate's
ability to communicate and execute a
campaign plan
so once we have that that situation uh
they can't de-platform you
without consequence and look i don't
know that there has been
in 2020 we'd have to look i don't know
that there has been a candidate that got
wiped off the map
but you see the way this is going and i
think that protection is
very well well warranted and and i think
it should be there
and just think if you're in october of
2022 and you have a
state senate race or something and they
do platform one of the two candidates
that is not that's going to have a huge
impact on the outcome of the race
yeah parlor they they we could talk
about the bias from twitter and facebook
as i said that's bad enough but what
they did with parlor
they just came in and he says
decapitated good word for it
this came in and wiped it out they
didn't like parlor said no you can't
have that
for years we were told oh if you if you
want uh if you want this
if you want your own kind of social
media platform then go set up your own
social media platform
all right we won't bother you over there
that isn't that always the the
trajectory isn't that always the theme
with the left but
they said no we we won't bother you just
just keep it to yourself
keep it in private and uh and and that's
fine we won't bother you
and so people went to parliament and
they said fine well we'll start our own
thing we're gonna go over here to parlor
and enough people went over there and
then the left said yeah never mind you
can't have that either
yeah it is it is time for legislative
solutions to this problem so i'm glad
that desantis is getting the ball
rolling
and i say again ron desantis 2024 he's
my that's definitely my early
frontrunner
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated